ever play a Bioware game like Mass
Effect or something and you run into the
scenario where you can gain Paragon or
renegade points depending on your choice
seebik Paragon because you want to be
good and then you realize the Paragon
choice just gave you a headache that's
what happened to these guys it's pretty
much it
lone survivor so lone survivor is the
true story of these four Navy SEALs who
go over to Afghanistan to get this
Taliban commanders in there and then
they run across a couple of civilians
who might be working with Taliban and
they're like what to do really so what
do we do we can let them go and have a
bunch of Taliban on our ass in the
middle of nowhere
or we can waste them and be dicks
ultimately they're like nah Paragon
points let's let them go and get the
hell out of here and go home because
they're gonna be coming round the
mountain when they come with hell the
hell is coming with them and that's
exactly what happens now these four Navy
SEALs are in the fight for their lives
to survive gotta say is some intense
seriously the best I can describe
this movie is that it's really real they
start getting into fire fighters it's
not all Michael Bay doubt you don't have
a hundred explosions with those
fireworks that come off the side you're
like the hell is that no this is
real stuff bullets and they're closed
and they're getting surrounded it's
really claustrophobic you can feel these
Taliban coming through the trees and
they're just being herded in directions
if it's like a nightmare or at least it
felt like left 4 dead waves of dudes
coming and you're trying to hold them
off your shooting get your buddies
within you're like we're not gonna live
dude we are not going to live it's
unsettling it's a really uncomfortable
feeling and you get to feel it and
that's really good when we can make you
feel the intensity like feel it to your
core not bad I was really surprised
Peter Berg directed this movie Peter
Berg directed battleship Hancock
wouldn't a fake this is a Peter Burke
movie however he also did movies like
Collateral sir like I think Peter Berg
is two different human beings sometimes
he does sloppy shitty messes other times
he does really good movies this is one
of the good movies and I really like the
fact that this movie Illustrated that
Afghanistan isn't all bad yeah there are
a lot of Taliban who hang out
down there and they're like death to a
lot of there are also really good
people down there they're like we're
civilians were town folk we don't want
to kill people
yeah those tell the banner dicks we're
not them with all you see in the news
it's really easy
get tunnel vision on that stuff like
Afghanistan's all bad they're
this movie did a good job at
illustrating no it's not like that the
world is not so simple I will say the
movie lacked on setup I mean it has set
up the best part of the setup was the
very beginning it shows real Navy SEAL
footage and training you're like oh
those guys gotta go through that they're
way tougher than me not hard to do I'm
just saying they're tougher than me that
was a lot more interesting than the
character setup where you're supposed to
be like oh these are the established
characters this is why we care I never
really felt that they got a couple of
briefings couple of hangout moments now
they're off to war and I'm like what are
their names again and I don't know lone
survivor is not this deep character
study movie or anything like that but it
is a really good and solid and
respectful representation as to what
these guys went through in that
situation one of the bummers that I've
already heard people being like that
American propaganda which makes
me think back to a simpler time that I
personally enjoyed remember a time where
you can make a war movie and it wasn't
seen as propaganda it just it
was a movie I miss those times it's a
good time it's unfair to trivialize the
movie as a whole by calling it
propaganda it's all I'm saying but in
the end I enjoyed lone survivor it was a
really realistic take on this war
situation that just went to really
fast everyone in the movie did a good
job it had a small cast but they all did
a good job the setup was a bit lacking
and there was a couple scenes where
you're like I was supposed to care about
that I didn't though although there are
definitely a couple moments where you're
like alright that more than makes up for
cuz I really care about this in the end
lone survivor is a very strong I would
buy it on blu-ray I would say lone
survivors not like Saving Private Ryan
it's more like this decades Black Hawk
Down there you go
that's a good way to say right so your
favorite war movie based on a real
situation they're out there in plenty
but what's your favorite whatever it is
comment below let me know and as always
if you liked what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more
you